white in Spanish okay and then you're
what kind of Indian
you're Bangladeshi
uh how'd you guys meet
Instagram he's living in the DMS what
was the message
you didn't meet through Instagram you
meant in high school
this guy really tried to dress up how he
met this girl like his messages are that
smooth that worked on you yo that's
embarrassing
what were you going through that that
got you did you look at his profile did
you see you had a good job what do you
do for a living
you work at Toyota or you work at a
Toyota dealership those are different
jobs the dealership girl what the
you doing
now my rich brown guys they're offer you
to date you set up with this
Corolla slinging
I'm not trying to oh hey for the record
I'm not trying to hurt anybody's
feelings we're gonna I'm gonna tease you
guys we'll make fun of me too but I'm
not trying to disrespect anybody real
quick I'll say that so if you don't want
to be talked to or if you feel like I
went too far just give me something like
this I'll move on does that sound good
okay beautiful beautiful all right yeah
you said Bring It On don't beat this out
of me change your mind is this your lady
right here
you say yes ma'am you ain't gonna do all
that bro I get it I'm little and I'm
built like a woman you don't need to do
all that though you this is your girl
how long y'all been together
two and a half years y'all didn't meet
on my Instagram
Halloween party what were you dressed as
Carnage
not too big to be dressed as no Marvel
third tier Marvel villain what the
are you doing damn Miami Girls Gotta
raise their standards I think y'all are
you're like a comic book guy then huh
yeah sure what the you mean yes
George he's not even in a movie dog
no yeah he is you see how you know
because you're a Marvel Superhero dork
dog
you know the actor bruh how are you
gonna pretend you're not a Marvel guy
no who else seen that
movie there you go
400 people staring at you like what the
I'm not gonna disappear with this
big about what he's talking
about nobody's told you this because
you're too big and scary but you're a
nerd though and that's good that makes
her feel safe probably because you're
big enough to protect her but too nerdy
to cheat on her
really makes you the ideal boyfriend
this is your homie right here your
brother
your little brother he looks like your
little brother I see it I see the
resemblance yeah yeah all right
you know them
yeah they're your cousins you only found
her nobody this is why Indians are the
best bro I'm not gonna have no lonely
ass cousin I'ma find her somebody
we need to get you a man
maybe what are you looking for Indian
I know a guy whose girl's probably not
gonna stay with him because he works in
a Toyota dealership
if you're interested
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]